[MUSIC PLAYING]
DENNIS MCLAUGHLIN: Students
come in with opinions already,
and they can say things
in a seminar that
are based upon just
their common knowledge
and not based on the readings.
CURT NEWTON: Today
on Chalk Radio,
we're exploring global food
production, water, and climate
change, and the
challenge of teaching
when polarized
opinions come to class.
DENNIS MCLAUGHLIN:
I'd say generally,
the students learn that
most of these issues
are more subtle and
complex than they thought
when they came in the class.
So one of the things that
happens at the end of the class
is, people's opinions
are usually not
as polarized as they
were in the beginning.
CURT NEWTON: I'm Curt
Newton, your guest host
for this episode of Chalk Radio.
At MIT, officially, I'm
director of MIT OpenCourseWare.
But for so many years at
MIT and in my personal life,
I'm also doing a lot of
work on climate change.
So when Sarah Hansen,
your usual host,
lined up this episode dealing
with these issues that
are so deeply personal for me
around climate change, food
systems, and water, and gave
me the chance to join in,
I jumped at it.
With prolonged droughts
made worse by climate change
affecting food
production and ecosystems
all around the world,
this conversation
couldn't be more timely.
Our guest, Dennis McLaughlin,
is a professor in MIT'S Civil
and Environmental
Engineering department,
and he's the instructor for
Course 1.74 Land, Water, Food,
and Climate.
Professor McLaughlin's
interest in hydrology and what
it can tell us about
our food systems
has been years in the making.
It all started back in 1991 on
a research trip that took him
halfway around the world.
DENNIS MCLAUGHLIN:
I went to Australia.
And there were a
lot of discussions
at the time about what was
sustainable food production
and whether or not Australia
could grow more food
with limited water
and the connection
between the availability
of water and the population
and food supply.
It struck me as a really
interesting application area
for hydrology.
CURT NEWTON: Dennis
explained that some
of the big wheat-growing
areas were becoming reliant
on irrigation to supplement
natural rainfall with water
pumped from underground
in order to keep
the crop big and healthy.
But over time, all
that irrigation
causes salts to
build up in the soil.
DENNIS MCLAUGHLIN: You
could go out in the fields
and see near the
irrigation ditches
just white layers of
salt accumulating.
It's the same kind
of problem that
ruined Mesopotamian
civilization millennia ago.
And it wasn't like it
was a big surprise.
But there was not
really a good mechanism
to encourage farmers to hold
back on their irrigation.
There was a lot of interest
in changing regulations
and incentives for
farmers to have
less adverse environmental
impact, especially
with salinity, and to make sure
that there was enough water
to keep the agriculture
economy healthy and going.
I mean, it's not a
reasonable solution
to say we won't have
any more farming,
and therefore we won't have
salt accumulation, and so on.
So it's that balance
between sustainable
use and economically
productive use that's tricky.
CURT NEWTON: This
experience in Australia
led to the creation of a course
on water usage and agriculture
and food systems.
It was here where Professor
McLaughlin recognized
that teaching these topics can
bring about an extra challenge.
DENNIS MCLAUGHLIN: One of
the interesting things about
the course, and a challenging
thing as a teacher,
is a lot of the
topics we talk about--
sort of like talking about
climate change, or GMOs,
or food waste, or
vegetarianism--
students come in with
opinions already.
And they can say things
in a seminar that
are based upon just
their common knowledge
and not based on the readings.
So for example, in
GMOs, the focus of most
of the students is,
oh, would GMOs hurt me?
Human health-- are they going
to cause me to have cancer
or whatever?
And that's really not the
scientific perspective
so much in GMOs, because
there's almost zero
evidence that any GMOs are
harmful to human health.
And they learn that
by reading the papers.
The problem is, what do
they do to the ecosystem,
and what do they
do to other plants
that are not
genetically manipulated,
and what are the unintended
consequences of GMOs,
because GMOs are generally
designed to help the farmer be
more productive.
One of the things that happens
at the end of the class is
people's opinions
are usually not
as polarized as they
were in the beginning.
CURT NEWTON: In my own
work on climate change,
I've certainly had
this experience
of trying to have conversations
with people coming out
of polarized opinions
and preconceived notions.
I was really curious
to hear how Dennis
moved beyond that in this class
and helped the students have
more productive
conversations to view
these sometimes controversial
issues from multiple angles.
DENNIS MCLAUGHLIN: It's really
just an introductory course.
And it's to kind of
stimulate interest
that they had when they
came in and show them
that it is possible to pursue
difficult topics by going
to the literature.
Many of them aren't used to
reading scientific papers,
the undergraduates especially.
They're used to
being lectured to
and things being in textbooks.
CURT NEWTON: And here's
where Dennis McLaughlin
gets creative.
For each article he
assigns, a student
is asked to present that
article to the class.
But Dennis also gives a
specific prompt to make sure
that these
presentations actually
help the students
understand the material.
DENNIS MCLAUGHLIN: Another
challenge in the course
is to make sure that
their presentations don't
bore the other students.
So I said, you just
have a minute or two,
and you should
pose some questions
for the class or some
issues and make them
as controversial as possible.
So that's what we try to do.
CURT NEWTON: As
controversial as possible?
Wouldn't encouraging
controversy just
prevent us from moving
beyond polarized opinions?
Dennis went on to explain
why controversy really
is productive and important
to deal with, especially
in science and
engineering classrooms.
DENNIS MCLAUGHLIN:
Another thing they're not
used to, the students, even
some of the graduate students,
is scientific controversy.
There's perhaps not that
much controversy, ironically,
interestingly, about GMOs.
But there's a lot of
controversy about things
like organic farming
and whether or not
we should be willing to
sacrifice yield a bit
to have more
sustainable agriculture.
And one of the things
we find out in the class
is, many people who are
organic farming advocates
are out of the mainstream of
the scientific literature.
But when you review the papers
on the other side that say,
for example, it's silly
to try to continue
smallholder farming in Africa.
Africa's agricultural
future should
be large, industrial farms,
perhaps run by foreigners
who buy or lease the land.
Some people write
assessments like that.
And you say, well,
yeah, but they're
being funded by the large
agricultural industry.
Well, does that
mean they're wrong?
Are they biased?
Well, I don't know.
But they become advocates, too.
So the students read
the papers, and we
try to discuss both sides of an
argument based on the merits.
And I'm not saying
students don't get exposure
to that kind of thing elsewhere.
But if they're taking
physics, and we're
talking about Newton's law, it's
not presented as a controversy.
CURT NEWTON: Motivating
students to engage
with the scientific literature
to unpack controversies
is only part of the work
involved in teaching
this engineering course.
There's something else, too,
something really important.
DENNIS MCLAUGHLIN:
It's a challenge
to decide how much
effort and discussion
to spend on learning
about scientific issues,
scientific controversies,
more or less agreed-on facts,
and how much to spend
on things like values,
because you really can't talk
about smallholder farming
unless you talk about poverty.
You can ask questions as to why
is the smallholder farmer so
poor?
Why does the smallholder kids
not want to stay on the farm?
They want to go to the city.
What do they do in the city?
Are there jobs there?
Well, do they have
any education?
Well, no, because the
smallholder farmer
doesn't have enough money
to send the child to school.
What about the role
of women in farming
and the role of
cultural differences
in how women are viewed?
And can they, for example,
participate in ownership?
You could just spend
the whole semester
talking about this stuff.
CURT NEWTON: Dennis's
course attracts students
from a wide variety of
disciplines and backgrounds.
And it's this diversity of
experiences among the students
that enriches the class for
everyone, including Dennis.
DENNIS MCLAUGHLIN:
I had a student
in the last class who was an art
student at Mass College of Art.
And she knew almost nothing
about engineering or science,
but she came from Venezuela
and settled in Puerto Rico,
and her aunt is a farmer.
And so she talked about how hard
it was for Puerto Rican farmers
to be competing with Central
American farmers, who
were very poor,
who were exporting
produce to Puerto Rico.
So Puerto Rico,
this place where you
can grow food all the time,
this very productive climate,
is not producing much food
for its own residents because
of pricing.
And she actually brought that to
the class and talked about it.
And I wouldn't have
even thought about it.
So there's this interaction
between the students who
have had farming experience or
just a student from Puerto Rico
who's talking to one
from Philadelphia,
and they're both from cities,
but they have a much different
perspective.
So not only did
the other students
learn from these students,
but I learned from them.
CURT NEWTON: As you may
have picked up by now,
climate change is an important
topic in this course.
We asked Dennis how
climate change will
affect food and agriculture.
DENNIS MCLAUGHLIN: Well,
that sounds like a question
we could pose in the class.
And we do discuss it
through reading papers.
So this is a big topic
and a controversial one.
One thing that there seems to
be pretty good agreement on
is if climate change
increases temperatures
during the growing
season sufficiently, that
will hurt agriculture.
But it depends on the
crop, depends on the place.
It's a lot different talking
about small increases
in average temperature
versus large increases
that could actually reduce
yield or even kill crops.
So temperature extremes
probably won't help.
CURT NEWTON: This course
really pushes its participants
to look beyond their
own assumptions.
Questions, contradictions,
uncertainties--
those are inevitable when
we take on topics as complex
as food, water,
and climate change.
Professor McLaughlin
embraces that
questioning as a core
part of the class,
even as he tries to
provide some answers.
DENNIS MCLAUGHLIN: Especially
undergrads, they're
used to going into class and
thinking they're learning,
quote, facts, and that's
the end of the story.
But I view the teacher as
kind of adjusting, resetting
the discussion to keep
things kind of on track
and consistent with the papers.
But giving the students the
freedom to say silly things
or to go beyond the
scope of the paper
is part of why they
like the course.
When they learned that there
are differences of opinion,
even among experts
and that there
are values, value
judgments, and that there's
social equity, and
all kinds of things--
they don't even connect that,
really, with formal education.
But it's not so easy
because, for one thing,
it takes the students
off balance a bit.
So it's definitely an
art, and you learn it
over multiple times.
You can't just start
the very first year
and be perfect on it.
So you have to learn the
teaching style as well
as the content.
You have to teach yourself how
to be observant to what works
and what doesn't.
CURT NEWTON: Maybe we could
all take a page or two
from Professor McLaughlin
and his students
and get a little
more comfortable
being knocked off balance.
Dennis' perspective made me
wonder how other educators
handle similar situations.
How do you integrate
conversations
about values and culture into
your science and engineering
courses in a way
that feels balanced?
You can share your insights
via the link in the show notes.
And we'll pass them along to
MIT faculty and listeners, who
could incorporate your
ideas into their teaching.
If you're interested
in learning more
about Professor
McLaughlin's work
or teaching with his open
educational resources,
you can check out his course,
1.74 Land, Water, Food,
and Climate, on our MIT
OpenCourseWare website.
It's one of over 150 courses
in OCW's extensive environment
courses collection.
And for even more, check
out the MIT Climate website
at climate.MIT.edu, where
you'll find a wealth of material
spanning these topics and more.
Thank you so much for listening.
Until next time, signing off
from Cambridge, Massachusetts,
I'm Curt Newton from
MIT OpenCourseWare.
Chalk Radio's producers include
Sarah Hansen, Brett Paci,
and Dave Lishansky.
Scriptwriting assistance
from Nidhi Shastri.
Show notes for this episode
were written by Peter Chipman.
We're funded by MIT Open
Learning and supporters
like you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]